into the floor just tremendous
try my best
that kyrie irving to join go ahead grant
kyrie what a fantastic game and you came
out from the start
locked in focused efficient just talk
about your mindset on the offensive
end tonight in this game well it was
going to be a tale of two halves
we knew that they were going to come out
aggressive they got two wonderful
players over there with a great
collection of guys and
uh you know we know that they're in
contention for uh
you know meeting us down the line so we
wanted to come out and make an
impression i felt like we did that
it was a total team effort uh you know
that's what it's going to take every
single night we got to get our defense
in order the last two games
we've been giving up a lot of points so
we want to buckle down on there
on the defensive end and just continue
to will ourselves the wins
hey great job congratulations man and uh
great defensive effort from you guys and
uh
good luck the rest of the way nice
brotherhood thanks thanks king
appreciate the brotherhood you already
know baby
i'm feeling the two club it's bursting
through the screen
[Music]
second half